and it is really sad about norm
and i'll tell you why i felt like it's
the most sad
you know i texted adam he get i texted
david spade people that i knew that knew
him decently
uh
you know norm had been a recluse for a
while
you know he'd really been one of those
whatever it is that boston spider or
whatever the thing that bites people or
something
gets
you know a lot of court-ordered
separation
or whatever i don't that's boston i
don't know i think i'm mixing things up
but a lot of dudes in boston have
restraining orders that's what i'm
saying
separately what i'm saying is that norm
was uh
he kind of stayed away from people it
seemed like to me
we reached out to him to have him on
i think there was some discussion about
it for a bit
uh between him and nick davis or his
producer and nick davis uh but
never made it happen i didn't know he
was struggling so bad i didn't hear even
that he was um
[Music]
the saddest part about it is that
or to me this is all just to me
and i'm just a human
uh
there's not a lot of comedians out there
there's not a lot of us
there's a little bit of comedian in all
of us
and i think uh there's not a lot of
comedians out there though and so when
you lose one of them and not to mention
one of the greats and one of the last
ones
that would speak his mind
it feels like you're losing a book
that nobody has copies of kinda
that's what it feels like i think
especially with norm like he
when you go watch him back on that joy
behar show or the one like the view
and he's just giving those [ __ ]
chubby thoughts the what for
you can just see they're all afraid to
speak anything that's not written on the
script from the producers and he's just
doing what he wants
and he stays there and he's got the joy
of just a mark norman the whole time
just this childhood fever that they
can't even fight
with their freaking money grub and trap
house
uh
um
soulless
uh
just lack it's not even comedy what any
of them do
it's not even and he shows up and just
toes they're like you're never gonna be
back and he's like good
good go watch that clip if you haven't
we'll put it in the clips that's a
special clip but the sad thing is
there's not a lot of comedians to when
you lose one not to mention one of the
greats and one of the rarest types
and i really say this as a famine i
don't even i mean i am a comedian but i
don't know if i feel like that sometimes
you know norm was from just a different
ilk
to be so sick and not even publicize it
but to be like imagine you go to the zoo
and they got like a white tiger in there
you know or white llama or whatever
and that [ __ ] hides away you know
everybody kids come they're spitting in
each other's mouths trying to pretend
like they're the llama or spitting in
each other's eyes you know eating
[ __ ] llama you know llama
you know
little llama dogs or whatever
you know just
just some some thick kids over there
just double llama dogging little
tiffany's over there
and she's gonna have trouble on junior
high i know that
but you know what i'm saying man uh
yeah yeah it's just heartbreaking i'll
tell you a good normal story so
the only one i really have
so
norm and i are doing a show in shawnee
oklahoma
at a casino and
there's an interesting group of people
there
you know it's a lot of d-list
celebrities like ourselves
um
it's a lot of oh the guy
from american idols pants on the ground
johnny or whatever it is jerry black
jerry
black jerry's there he's pulling his
pants up and down and up and down i
think his legs almost came at one point
his pants had just crossed over him so
much but anyway this dude's in the lobby
he's got his pants up he's got his pants
danny's got his just [ __ ] he's got an
extra he got a pants and a bag next to
him just people throwing pants on it
doesn't even you know
they're just pants and are just oh just
pants pants pants this [ __ ] guy you
remember him golden jerry or whatever it
is black golden jerry dark jerry
chocolate jerry or something the singer
looking like a fool with my pants on the
ground you know what i'm saying then he
okay the show ran late because he
brought his girlfriend out
okay
like tits in the [ __ ] wild
johnetta or something
so he's like look uh i love you because
i think he had to do a certain amount of
time he brought her out and then he
repeated tits on the tits on the side
tits on the tits on the ground i don't
know what it was this [ __ ] i don't
even know this [ __ ] got a briefcase
full of tits i don't know what's going
on okay i'm upstairs baby
i'm not downstairs dealing with the [ __ ]
hello serious
so anyway i'm up there and uh finally
it's my turn to go on
and because there's a comedy show the
night before there's a poker game the
next day
so this is the comedy show i'm opening
up for norman
norm sorry
i'm sorry mr mcdonald
norm
well i went over i was trying to prove
myself i think i was
i felt
probably some sense of entitlement or i
just went over i don't know
i'm not a big light runner or
i don't know i have my moments i'm not
like a black guy
black guy run the light two and a half
hours
and that's not even a red that ask
anybody
that's what they do
so anyway i uh i'm running i'm black
guying i'm up there black guy i'm going
long adam eager is there with norm who i
didn't even know at the time
who would turn out to be the booker at
the comedy store and one of my closest
friends actually and i love you adam if
you hear this just know i love you
um
and i'm sorry you lost your buddy
so the next one uh the next morning i'm
downstairs it's a poker tournament
jerry mathers is there the beaver
and jerry mathers as the beef
he's there
i go say i'm sorry to norm
norm's looking around the room
a lot of chicks in there not really a
lot there's a couple checks and
dude's in there with bigger tits than
women it's [ __ ] oklahoma people's
thick people's double bone you got a
dude in there with nine shoulders you
got a dude selling [ __ ]
uh
selling meat right off his own body you
know you go to some of those middle
eastern shops and they're just cutting
meat right off the thing this dude's
doing that right off his arm
just right off of
just chopping it right onto a damn bread
people's over there buying meat off you
know people that buying damn pack of six
subs right off this dude's tricep
so anyway man we got it going
everybody's doing decent and uh
and i go over to norm i apologize and uh
he goes man there's a lot of hot
[ __ ] in here isn't there
and i'm looking around the room and
there isn't
there is not
there there was not
but i i think he's serious you know so
i'm just like i'm like oh here's a guy's
a little bit older yeah
so i say yeah man sure is a lot of
hotties in here
and he goes the [ __ ] there are
okay
and it just [ __ ]
man it took me to another level because
here i am thinking i'm placating this
guy's a little bit older than me
make him think yeah these chicks are hot
man i'm going to agree with you yeah bud
a lot of huddy's in here
and the whole time he knew he knew he
was older than me he knew that i was
thinking he thought these women were hot
and uh
and there it was
you know
he had his own
you know some humor is a maze i think
in some comedians they make it's a maze
it's a maze that
sits between them and the world
and the way
that the humor is created is
is that some people have such a unique
maze something people would set up punch
that's a small maze that set up punch
some people it's the element of surprise
some people it's
it's just
extremely direct and dry
but i think norm just had his maze was
just different
and i don't think you can create that i
think it's built into you
and uh
one of a kind man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you